hello and welcome to see your plane
demented monkey that's a funny name I
haven't played a man norway norwegian
flag so let's see what we get again this
stuff are you guys you want to bore me
to death or what the ID quincy 7 is not
the most solid move ever but it's a way
to ya get some kind of thing going in a
little bit more non-symmetrical than
others Queen takes is actually
interesting move here I made a mistake
here d5 I have to play first yeah okay
not ideal shape lately five first okay
yeah the screens is seven is a line that
keeps a little bit of tension of course
black and play e6 g6 whatever and be
okay I mean the white the white setup is
some very neat but if you want to get
something going playing it a little bit
in a non-symmetrical Wayne is a good
option cannot go bishop edge for because
of night f4 so I get the important
bishops and I think I'm happy here
who can cancel that one as well that
tried to be a little bit quicker their
latest games I had those big time
problems every every time every game
yeah me what why does he weaken himself
like that it's a very surprising
decision um okay I can take Joey five I
mean this is the easiest way like just
just do this and then hard to believe
that this shouldn't be good for black so
I'm stumbling here
so my goal here is to make sure that
both my bishops get some player the
center is a little bit it's quite
imposing I mean it's not so easy to to
handle the bishop so that they can do
something it may be rook situ is an idea
to take be to end the night it's not at
all these event of what interior losses
them would seem
hmm
not sure what white should do it so it's
not snotty ZM he has got very little
coordination yeah this is a move i was
thinking of as a possible possible idea
yeah look T 1 attending whoopsie to see
one I was thinking of Roger try to get
to the king well maybe look a one looks
looks okay though night c4 i have d 5 i
think if he tries to or bishop a 6 is
also a good move and maybe you just
place night be three now to this one
okay okay so i can i can play will see
to see one but i can't start with this
move this is an interesting choice I
think making sure that he has not an
easy escape square with the king it
weakens the light squares but group to
see one is a pretty pretty awful threat
so what is he doing here Bishop e2 or
something and look be one
it looks pretty bad
okay so if I now invade okay I should
just I can play sorry i can't play
Bishop before as well takes rook takes
isn't bad but this must be right okay
must be okay yes so now i can take here
and then i have rook and two bishops but
not quite sure about this if this is so
great actually
this is a this material it's not that
easy to handle he has screens you three
at the end I can take on your forward
though and I don't see how we double a
text stuff okay so I'm taking it now
it's difficult fact that the center and
both bishops are attacking it yeah so we
had to open up one of the diagonals how
to do the same I can take be too maybe
nope we need to burn Queen Queen attack
said that Bishop here is a little bit a
little bit in danger like to get a 2g
form
how do i get that coordinated now as I
said that it's not that easy that the
all pieces are kind of unprotected at
the moment h4 is an idea if you takes a
look at form that's pretty aggressive I
come on let's do it let's do it would
probably help if it takes rook checks to
g4 and then Bishop f5 it's also not bad
I was I wanted to go bishop CA too but
I'm warning IMA okay 23 is not possible
got ya I can take it it was a bit of a
scale like resemble that is not possible
but then it is really quite easy now
because I get Bishop b5 and then sorry
then he collapses on the kingside jam it
was somewhat surprising what you did
there with this f4 and giving you the C
file and such was a little bit little
bit strange I was thinking actually have
threatening to take on d4 already and
those kind of strategic a threat but he
totally totally ignored it and even
weakened the position with f4
tremendously channel okay the engine is
just saying a black wins easily but it's
not as I said not that easy because of
the coordination problems that that you
have here night be three years good for
wide so I already screwed it up look a
one is the bad move and this actually is
clearly better for black and you six
blocking everything this is the computer
line no black ass more comfortable and
here okay night be three hmm yeah my
rook it doesn't have many squares and
this is indeed true and Queenie to with
the kepler basically trapped the rook
okay it was a good moment and tok rook
e1 was stronger even so i had a computer
as typically merciless this is very
strong a lot stronger than what I did
because again it's a little bit it's not
so easy to coordinate and I think h4 was
a good one TM yeah I'm probably winning
I mean not just engine wise and probably
am I will manage this that's what I'm
trying to say we should have eight and
this is reasonably safe okay tough tough
still in and that be 31 the chance for
him okay well thanks for watching